hey 42 here how would you dispose of a
body there are countless ways or so I've
been told but one 20th century Italian
woman had a method of disposing of
bodies that even mrs. Lovett and her
PI's would have been disgusted by serial
killer
Leonarda Cianciulli turned her victims
into bars of soap and tea cakes and
that's not even the worst bit but before
we get into that let's learn a little
about what drove her to murder in the
first place
psychologists have long believed that an
unsteady upbringing can contribute to
one becoming a psychotic murderer
both Stalin and Hitler had a highly
dysfunctional childhood Leonarda
Cianciulli is no exception to this rule
she was born out of rape in 1894 in
Montella Italy her mother never wanted
her yet she was left with no choice but
to raise her safe to say
Leonarda had a rather dysfunctional
upbringing at the age of 23 Leonardo
defiantly married a local registry clerk
against the wishes of her parents her
mother was so upset with her that she
cursed the newlyweds Leonardo had always
been a highly superstitious and paranoid
person so she took a lot of offense to
this curse things quickly got worse from
here Leonardo got pregnant 17 times
three were lost two miscarriages and 10
offers died when they were very young
who knows whether this was just a series
of extremely unfortunate coincidences or
had she really succumbed to the evil
ways of her mother's curse and needless
to say
Leonardo became ultra protective over
her four remaining children she sought
help by visiting a fortune-teller who
decided that this poor woman's life
wasn't already tragic enough and told
her that she would either end up in
prison or a criminal asylum despite
being an ultra paranoid potential
psychopath on the brink of a mental
breakdown always going well for a while
for Leonardo and her four children until
one of their lives came under threat in
1949 her eldest son decided to fight for
the Italian
me in World War 2 Leonarda didn't like
this and couldn't bear the thought of
losing another child
so she came up with a genius plan
she concluded that if she found another
human sacrifice they would surely take
her son's place in the afterlife and so
her son would somehow be supernaturally
protected from death and so she set out
to find her victim Leonardo was actually
an amateur fortune-teller herself and
she often practiced on the local women
in her village now I'm not sure exactly
how you practice what you telling
presumably you just keep on guessing
until you get something right she chose
her first victim carefully Faustina sati
was a client of Leonardo's and during
one session Leonardo told a depressed
and helpless Faustina that she would
find the husband of her dreams and her
life would be all rosy if she were to
leave town and travel to a neighboring
town
she also cleverly instructed Faustina
that she must immediately write letters
to all her friends and family informing
them that she intended to travel to
another town to find a husband and so
Leonardo thought she had created the
groundwork for the perfect murder
Faustina visited Leonardo one last time
before she left town and Leonardo poured
two glasses of wine as a toast to fruss
Tina's new life in her new town of
course first Eanes wine was drugged with
sedatives after she was out cold
Leonardo bludgeoned her helpless victim
to death with an axe and so began
Leonardo's twisted method of disposing
of the corpse first she chopped the
corpse into 9 equal sized pieces to make
it more manageable she drained the blood
then put the dried pieces into a giant
pot along with caustic soda a primary
ingredients in soap making and yes she
then turns the corpse bits into bars of
soap which seems almost comical when you
learn what she did with the blood from
the body leonardo dried the blood in
another mix
it with eggs flour sugar milk chocolate
and margarine because you know if you're
going to make delicious delicacies out
of dead humans at least have the decency
to make them low-fat
she then baits this sickening mixture
into Italian tea cakes and then she
shared the tea cakes around her
neighbor's even more disturbingly
Leonardo and her son ate them up also
Leonardo went on to carry out the same
murderous process on two more of her
female fortune-telling clients her final
victim was a local soprano called
Virginia Cacioppo Leonardo later wrote
in her memoirs that she had flesh that
was fat and white and apparently she
made a most acceptable creamy soap also
Leonardo noted that Cacioppo made the
best tea cakes so far a quoting that
woman was really sweet the words don't
even exist to describe how truly
disturbed this woman was but the sweet
taste wouldn't last too long because the
sister of Leonardo's final victim grew
suspicious of her disappearance and she
informed the police that she had last
seen her sister Virginia Cacioppo
entering the home of Leonarda Cianciulli
leonardo was swiftly arrested and she
confessed to all of her messed up soapy
tea cake murders she was sentenced to 30
years in prison and three years in a
criminal asylum for the mentally ill
just as the fortune teller had predicted
all those years ago thanks for watching
if we go back to the Middle Ages or even
all the way back to the Roman Empire was
life ever any better than it is right
now Andrew Wakefield published a
research paper claiming that there is a
strong link between vaccinations and the
onset of autism